hi and welcome to the introductory video
about vaccinations in this video we are
going to talk about how vaccinations
developed what is the concept behind it
and what are the types so these days we
are pretty much aware of flu vaccine and
vaccine of several other diseases but
where does the concept of vaccination
come from so in late 18th century people
are affected by smallpox and it became a
big pandemic but at that point of time
it turns out the milkmaids who used to
milk the cows they are pretty much
immune to the smallpox and they don't
develop scars and this phenomenon was
detected by Edward Jenner but these milk
meats they have small blister in their
hands from cow pox now cow pox is not
that powerful virus and it don't infect
human that much so they have small
blisters in their hand
now Edward Jenner thought if you can
take out the extract from the partials
of these milkmaids they wouldn't have
developed cow pox and then it can he can
inject that into a person and that
person might get immuned right and he
has seen that the milkmaids
are mostly not infected by the smallpox
and that's what he did with his garden
and son and what happened is after
injection there was no symptoms of
smallpox when this person was infected
with the smallpox virus he is not
showing any symptoms of smallpox that
means his immune system has fought back
again this particular virus from that
the initial concept or initial initial
foundation of vaccine was actually
formed now vaccination gives us
protection from all kind of viral
attacks or pathogenic attacks so let's
see how does it work so vaccines can be
roughly divided into two different
strategies of immunization passive
immunization
and an active immunization in case of
passive immunization you use the
antibodies which are going to be
produced by the body and you ready madly
supply that and in case of active
immunization you put or you expose the
body to less harmful state of the
pathogen let's say a heat shield or
let's say inactivated virus now let's
talk about the passive immunization
first and then we go to active
immunization in the case of passive
immunization what you generally do is
against a pathogen you put the
antibodies so whenever your pathogen is
infecting your body your antigen
presenting cells would be active they
would work but at the time they they
would take some time to produce like
antibodies so when the b-cells would
produce antibody it would be already
pretty much time right and then the
pathogens would be neutralized now if
you ready mentally supply these
antibodies because you know these
antibodies are against that particular
pathogen so you'd get quick augmentation
response and that's how a passive
immunization work it is antibody
mediated but there is major risk
associated with this kind of
immunization strategy let me tell you
how so let's say you are bitten by a
snake and this snake venom is
detrimental for you in order to come to
the snake venom you have injected
yourself with antiserum now this anti
serum has actually antibody against the
snake venom which is raised in either
rabbit or in horse now if you give this
antiserum it would neutralize the toxin
or neutralize the poison and as a result
the person would be saved but there is
another problem since this antiserum the
antibodies are actually not crazed in
human human immune system would find it
foreign and it would mount a response
against those antibodies as a result
huge antibody clumps would be produced
which would be attracting the attention
of other cells such as neutrophils and
macrophages as a result these clumps can
also
block the blood vessels and allow
neutrophil to attack the cells of the
blood vessels leading to damage or
expansion of these capillaries so type 3
hypersensitive response can be evoked if
the dosage is not proper so passive
immunization though it's a temporary
remedy but it has a lot of risk
associated with it now let's talk about
active immunization which involves the
formation of memory cells the memory
cells would have a memory of what
pathogen has invaded so they would
quickly target those pathogen and know
what type of antigen this pathogen has
produced so a memory cell would quickly
get differentiated into a specific kind
of plasma cell which has antibody
against that particular pathogen and
this response would be very rapid so
let's say you have injected the pathogen
or injected these kind of injected this
kind of vaccination strategy or the hit
kill pathogen then there is a primary
immune response and second time when
you're really exposed to that kind of
pathogen then what happens there is an
augmentation of the response and your
body reacts faster because already there
are memory b-cells or memory cells
produced inside the body so the memory
cell knows which antibody to produce and
what isotype to produce so they know
from the the plasma cells which are
derived from these memory cells they
already know that which antibody to
produce so the lag between making the
antibody to kill the pathogen is very
low and this time the response is way
more effective that is why you vaccinate
let's say your early age and you're
still immune to a particular infection
in your early 20s let's say that is how
a vaccination is so effective in in case
of active immunization strategy and let
us take a look from 90s to 2000 I mean
this years from nineteen si in the
friend in century 2 to that when th
century how the smallpox has diminished
in many parts of the world after
vaccination so that is how the X vaccine
work
I hadn't discussed about the exact
strategies and more detailed ways by
which active immunization or passive
immunization can work but in other
videos I will be talking about that so
till now if you like this video give it
a big thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you